Thank You Pete good off from everyone
thanks for joining after a lunch session
I know it's sometimes you know tricky so
okay we have 30 minutes so I'll be
jumping into the agenda and you know
I'll just set the stage so we're gonna
talk about spot lengths it's an
open-source tool it the talk will
revolve around the performance tuning
like the traditional way of tuning your
spark application and how you can become
you know scientific and actually reduce
efforts because there's a lot of effort
required those who are actually doing
active work in spark they can easily
relate sometimes it takes hours days
even weeks and I'm not kidding so let's
jump into the agenda very quick
introduction of mine I have been in data
space for more than a decade I am an
engineer at the core started with
Microsoft back in 2006 then I work for
another data company then joined cueball
and I've been working with cueball for
last six years and as you can imagine
like you know spark kind of you know got
introduced somewhere around 2014 so I
have been a witness of the journey of
you know spark adoption in the community
have been helping multiple customers in
last so many years I can talk about all
the stories you know where things fail I
mean I personally have experience in
kind of you know those those things so I
would be happy to share in our office
hours all right
so the agenda will revolve around as I
mentioned performance tuning pitfalls
then we'll jump into the theory behind
you know spark lines what it is about
and how it is solving that problem and
then I'll share some examples as well
with some screenshots and everything
there's a war story and I hope I'll get
you know time to really talk about that
so just to set the stage
I assume like you know most of you might
be doing sparked today so this is not
something very new to you guys but those
who might not be aware of that this is a
simple structure of your application so
on the left side you see there is a
driver program which is a single
process it's a JBM you can imagine and
then this guy is responsible for in
Ossining so many executors it could be
hundreds of executors on a very big
production pipeline if you're
experimenting something it might be some
four or five executors but I have been
dealing with a lot of you know these
scenarios where people are running like
five hundred executors or thousand
executors and sometimes you can imagine
like you know one executor might just be
working or occupying the entire node so
when I say executors you can think or
relate with the infrastructure cost and
infrastructure utilization and things
like that so I just wanted to set this
you know stage here with this okay
Before we jump into sparklines so I'll
talk about how people actually do tuning
right because we we all know that you
know spark runs pretty fast it does so
and so very well but often times I see
people take the approach on the left
side which is brute force what that is
if you just write on Google you say how
to tune your spark program you find some
six seven nine parameters people suggest
that hey increase your driver memory
increase their executors memory GC
overhead this and that and people just
apply it without getting the context and
what happens sometimes you get
successful because imagine right I mean
you you maybe you were having the same
problem which gets solved by that but
that's really not the right way
sometimes you struggle a lot and then
you take away a very bad perception that
hey spark doesn't work or this and that
so that's the you know brute force
approach the right side talks about the
job diagnosis and experiments which is a
very logical very scientific approach I
personally have been using that what
that talks about is spark at UI analysis
so those who are aware of it sparked
provides a very nice UI it shows you all
the stages all the tasks where you can
do lot of things like you know you can
sort by time taken by it you can figure
out whether there's a data skew or not
things of that nature if there is things
failing in their driver log you can just
analyze the log you can find out that
there is a network timeout and things of
that sort it gives you a good good good
idea that you know what what what needs
to be done here right although it's
sometimes or it is always iterative
right I mean I find some clues there i I
think that oh I need to actually tune
so-and-so here then I apply those
settings then I
that query or that workload now imagine
in production pipeline you sometimes hit
production pipeline which are like you
know it runs for nine hours or 12 hours
now you can imagine like you know
repeating the task for 12 hours again is
gonna be killer right you don't want to
do that and we'll relate this with the
sparkling philosophy right I mean
sparklines tries to solve your problem
without doing those experiments it
provides you good reports so that you
can act on it and you can apply those
things it also does some simulation and
projections that hey what if you if
you've done this you would achieve so
and so results so on the left side that
brute force approach is very unreliable
very wasteful like you know you might
spend too much of resources
infrastructure resources or the human
resources on the right side it is great
but it sometimes might take that
developer cost like you're not doing
iterative analysis and things some of
the key factors which we'll talk about
and I I will relate what what drives
poor performance right I mean these are
not this is not limited to this but some
of the key areas like you know resource
utilization like memory and CPU which
I'm sort of alluding towards your
executor size your driver size and
things of that sort
driver only faces I'll explain this in
the further slide what I mean by that
task force is number of executors course
like sometimes just to give you a very
simple example let's say I have five
tasks it naturally it obviously doesn't
make sense to use ten executors for that
right so that's a simple concept that
you know you should not be over
provisioning where you you're not
leveraging things that's why you're
gonna lose either you have to increase
your task or you need to reduce your
executors it's cute task all of us who
have been doing sequel for last so many
years can easily understand what I see
skewed ask and it happens in spark as
well there's nothing new about it then
we'll talk about there are some
scalability limits right so there's
always a notion that hey if my
application is running slowly I just go
and basically increased number of
executors that is what you find in that
brute force approach I was talking about
like people just suggest that hey you
you increase your executors and things
like that so I'll talk about the
scalability limits like you know there
are certain thresholds certain caps
where you you by adding executors you're
not going to help your application okay
so this particular slide is very
important and
I'll try to explain so that this sets
the whole kind of you know roadmap for
next few minutes so that you can relate
so how to read this slide so you you
should look at this from the left to
right left side is basically your t0 in
the time stamp so this is like us
journey of the entire application right
this application I am depicting here is
having one driver and for course course
for simplicity sake you can imagine like
there are four executors each executor
is having one core now this journey
starts from driver right so I'll quickly
touch upon what driver does but think
about driver as a coordinator it
basically plans your spark code it
basically does a lot of things and as I
mentioned it is a single process right
so while this guy is doing its own work
and planning for giving executors more
work your executors are sitting idle
right so that is the key here so the
reason we are talking about this slide I
just wanted to give a sense that how to
measure your utilization and your
performance so in this slide you see
these blueish spots there are three or
four of those and in that particular
window your executors are not being
utilized at all and why it is important
to understand because as I'm initially
mentioned that some applications might
be having hundreds of executors so
thinking of that thing that you know if
whatever if you're hundreds of executors
are sitting idle even if it is one
minute you can multiply the resource
wastage so this is the key of it and and
by the way in this diagram I am just
showing stage three stages I can tell
you in the real practical applications I
generally encounter like 50 60 or 70
stages and there's a lot of such you
know spots where driver is doing the job
and rest of the things are not happening
and stuff like that we'll jump into that
but this is extremely important so in
this particular slide how to interpret
it whatever is the white space is total
waste you're basically wasting your
resources these executors are sitting
idle and this is what you have to
minimize the question is can you
minimize it to the heard sort of you
know zero percent where you you have no
wastage that's practically not possible
because driver is always going to be
your single point of bottleneck you call
that but how can you minimize it is what
we are going to
in sparklines principles and and the
implementation so this slide talks about
minimize doing nothing that is what I
was saying like you know how to minimize
this whitespace driver-side computation
I talked about so basically what what it
tells me that you know we need to
minimize our driver-side computation
oftentimes those who are in Python space
are doing data signs they can easily
relate like you know it is a very I
should not say bad habit but you know
Python guys always jump on like you know
their Python pandas and all those things
and they start coding that now in the
spark world if you're doing those kind
of stuff it basically falls on your your
driver because ultimately to paralyze
your stuff you need to leverage your
executor and you need to use spark api's
wherever you are just falling on your
single threaded or single api of python
you it it is likely to go into the
driver only so just be aware of that
aspect so ultimate goal is to minimize
driver side computation there are more
things we will probably touch upon those
so while we are talking about driver
again and again what it does so some of
you like you know who are doing like you
know running queries and stuff like that
so you can easily relate it does file
listing and split computation what it is
it is like a planning right so when look
for example I am running some PI spark
code and I'm doing hype contacts I I
want to read some table it basically
does file listing split computation
creates a plan for its executors and
things like that that all happens and
driver and as I initially mentioned it
is practically not possible to minimize
the driver side compute to zero because
this is anyways this has to happen it's
an integral part of the entire
application loading of hype tables file
output committer all not going to the
deeper details of that but basically
there are certain things which are
offloaded to driver after every stage
and after the job completion and that
has to happen like file output commit
commit has to happen in driver like note
there are some optimizations cueball has
done we will talk about that offline in
our office hours similarly like you know
in in python there is in in spark there
is a collect api people have this
tendency to just do compute collect some
ten records hundred records all those
things actually rely upon your driver
and I was talking about pandas right I
mean there's a
very popular API to pandas people
convert that I mean there's a new open
source project arrow which basically
tries to help there so I'm just touching
upon some of these aspects that I know
how it impacts or how driver impacts
your performance right moving on
there is another so in while I'm showing
this I'm talking about some potential
problems or some common problems right
now this is another example where you
don't have enough tasks you have more
executors than you then your task and
that is quite visible that in stage two
on the bottom of it you have one white
box what that means is you actually have
four cores but your number of tasks in
that stage at one point was three and
then next point was just one as you can
see on the top right I mean so this is a
classic example that your application
configuration is not great while you are
throwing lot of resources a lot of
infrastructure it's not leveraging that
that you have to minimize and why we are
talking about it's parklands actually
helps you identify these things in a
very user friendly manner in a very nice
UI we will touch upon that controlling
number of tasks so how do I control my
tasks like you know what do I do about
it so there are a bunch of things which
actually drive this number of tasks per
stage a very basic thing is about your
data right let's say you you're just
dealing with one gigabyte data I won't
expect that thing to go into like you
know millions of tasks obviously because
you may have very small files still like
you know you're some intermediate stage
will be actually combining those things
it you might be dealing with like few
like maximum tens of tasks not not
hundreds there is a block concept you
might be aware of it right then there is
shuffle partition so those who write
sparks equal or even PI spot you guys
can shuffle reshuffle your stages so
while first stage had 200 tasks you can
always reach shuffle it to 400 or 100 so
this is something those those those are
the livers which you have in your
application programming you can do we
partition is kind of a reshuffling it's
it's another thing like I we just we
partition the number of partitions and
you can change that number so these are
the driving factors and sometimes there
are some hard dependency in your program
logic where you probably cannot do much
about your task like for example if
you're doing single order y on all sort
of things so there are those
possibilities so I just wanted to touch
upon this aspect now there is another
thing what sometimes drives you know
crazy applications like you know where
you wonder like why it is happening its
tasks queue so imagine you're doing some
join and that joint has asked you those
like you know I'm sure everyone would be
familiar there's some bad key or there's
very popular key let's say you are doing
country-wise whatever right join and
some country has particular distribution
at a higher range quite possible that
those tasks which are processing data
for that particular country or that code
or ID will be taking more time what this
tells me that you know you have to
either minimize it or you have to set
your expectations because at individual
task level if there are skews then you
certainly cannot go below that so all
I'll introduce a concept of critical
path soon and we'll talk about that as
well but your task skew is another
factor which basically sets some level
of limits to your application so unless
you solve those skews you cannot reduce
the time taken by our wire application
for example in this diagram itself as
you can see there are stages like stage
one has complete white space here
Stage two has that white space but what
is happening is there are some tasks
those top tasks are basically scoota
they are taking longer and if you add
all these kind of you know time windows
that is your critical path so what what
it means no matter how many executors
you throw on this application these Q
tasks are gonna hold the entire
application for that duration because
they have to complete no matter how many
executors are there it's not gonna help
your application so that is the critical
path so these arrows if you just add
them you will find you will derive that
number that you know this is the minimum
time my application is going to take
beyond that I cannot go no matter how
many executors I'm going to throw to my
application
now sparklines also talks about ideal
application time so in the report it
also shows you and how does it derive
that ideal application time
so and I'll cover that but what
sparklines does it does some level of
you know your scheduling simulations at
a logical layer it doesn't really run
much but basically based on the metrics
and all those things so it figures out
that you know what is the median time of
each task and what if there was no data
skew right based on certain projections
it basically determines that hey if you
solve all those problems your ideal
application time could drastically go
down to XYZ so it actually gives you a
certain practical it set your
expectations right I mean sometimes the
expectation could be crazy like hey my
application runs in 120 minutes what how
do I run it in three seconds I mean
that's something it's a good desire to
have but ideal application notion
basically gives you a practical limit
that hey based on all those good things
you probably can reduce her time to 13
minutes and it is it is not like you
know some random projection based on
your your application cycle or the
journey based on the medium of each task
each stage it calculates and it shows
you that so it sets a good target which
is achievable and of course you might
have to change some application code
that also it provides those hints okay
so now introducing sparklines so this so
far I was just setting the foundation
the philosophy behind it it's an open
source spark profiling tool it's
available in github anyone can go start
using it you know and you if you want to
contribute we would love to you know see
that as well the great thing about this
is it runs on any spark deployment it it
could be while q-ball is a cloud native
company or offering is all you know in
as your AWS and everything but spark
lensses purely you know built for any
spark deployment it could be on Prem it
could be any other deployment any other
vendor all you need to do is certain
small things which I'll talk about soon
what it does it helps you take the right
decisions without many experiments as I
already mentioned that you know there is
a there is a logical way where you can
do a lot of experiments you can try
things out based on some of your reading
some of your findings but it gives you
that one shot where you can always
figure out that hey this is my limit
this is what I can achieve so in in the
right on the right side you see it tells
you the executor wall clock time total
wall clock time
and on the right in my right side of the
image it basically shows you the
critical path so that critical path
tells me that no matter how if you if I
add more executors it's not gonna go
below 19 seconds it tells me the actual
runtime one minute five seconds it also
gives me ideal application time concept
that hey within this set of
configuration if there was no tasks
queue my application could run in 59
seconds so this diagram actually tells
me that there is not massive data skew
in my in my application there's some
some other issue right I mean because
even the ideal application time is is
shown as 59 seconds how do I use
sparklers it basically you know as you
can see there is a github link and how
do I use the this yellow text if you
look at that is all you have to do you
have to apply the artifact ID there may
be an artifact idea of sparklines and
then you have to add the extra listener
so just to give you give you some
context sparklines is actually nothing
but it implements spark listener
interface right it intercepts some of
those values does those simulation and
projections and gives you the results so
all you have to do is append these two
lines into your code and that's all
there are other things as well how can I
run a spark lines on my application
which is already run you can always do
that so there are a bunch of steps
available on this github link please
feel free and check it out alright so as
I already spoken like you know
sparklines philosophy revolves around
these things like you know what is my
wall clock time what is the critical
path and what what is my ideal
application time however if you look at
the report it generates it actually
provides you much more it gives you a
graphical picture of your entire
projection as well that hey your
application has 30 executors it takes X
number of seconds what if you make it
thirty five or forty or fifty five how
much time it might you know you how much
time you can your application will take
to finish so it shows you those charts
and everything so please check it out
it's very easy to use but primarily on
top of everything it revolves around
those couple of things and then you can
take your decisions based on that this
is the URL I was talking
about so this is this is an URL anyone
can access you can generate your
sparklines report using those steps I
mentioned earlier and that JSON file you
can just you have uploader here on this
webpage you can upload and you can
generate the report and what you see on
the screen is the kind of report
snapshot you can you can you can look at
right I mean it shows you certain
projections so and utilization charts
and everything
ok here I'm gonna talk about couple of
examples I I have two examples today
I'll talk about both the the first
example is very simple it is like you
can easily relate in your day-to-day
life like you know what you what goes on
and what happens so let's jump into it
so on the left top top left corner you
have our sparks equal it is doing like
you know fancy stuff it is simply
counting some attributes for poor state
by doing a join between two tables right
and I generated this report so on the
right side if you see some of these bars
it it gives me some data points that
actual run time is two minutes ideal
application time if I you know so
critical path is 21 seconds ideal
application time is whatever writes one
minute 53 seconds so it tells me that if
I don't change anything this is gonna be
my my you know expectation here now on
the bottom side there is a report where
I marked something so it also tells you
the task is queue what you call
multiplier or whatever I mean so what it
means is there are some tasks which are
actually skewed at that particular
multiplier like you know they take
nearly for 4x time compared to the
average task you know time taken by
average tasks so it clearly tells me
that there is a skew problem with my
application so what I did I looked into
my code again I looked into my join key
so whenever there is a skew your join
and your group bias these are your usual
suspects so I looked into my my code and
I I thought like you know why am I doing
this why not I calculate the count first
and then join it and then make some out
of it
how does it help so it helps me because
when I do inner query and the count
already it basically reduces my skew
because in join you can imagine like if
I join four rows versus four rows it's
gonna generate sixteen rows right I mean
so what I'm doing is I'm just flattening
the left side of table before I go for
join so it definitely minimizes some
some power of my skew so the same code
which is going to generate the same
output
now finishes in one minute five seconds
as you can see on the right side it it
basically gives me all those things and
also if you look at tasks queue it has
reduced from nearly 4 to 2.75 there's
still some tasks queue because I'm sure
the other side of the table had lot of
duplicate you know what is store SK
store key so there were still some some
possibilities to minimize it but I
wanted to show this example quickly that
it didn't take much time for me to
really figure out that hey what should i
attack on like you know what kind of
things I need to I need to work on
without in absence of this I would have
worked on some increasing executors and
things like that what if it would have
resulted into like not much it would
have changed much for me and and I would
have wasted time and all those kind of
stuff so this is a good example which I
was just running over the beacon the
next exam example talks about a very
classic case of really lengthy code and
really huge application I think that
whole thing went on for about a couple
of days so let's dive into that quickly
so this is this talks about around six
hundred three lines of Scala code elf my
teen works with the customers we
generally get issues like hey this is
the code it's not working as expected
what can you guys do for that and we
always help people but the biggest
challenge is like you know it is
somebody else's code six hundred three
lines of Scala code you can imagine
first you need to interpret first and
second you need to understand the data
sets but what we did we just ran the
first pass of the you know spark lines
we ran on it it took about 2.5 hours 158
minutes as you can see the total wall
clock time and the critical path with
that kind of set of it it says that it
it is 127 minutes so basically it is
saying that you know no matter
adding more executors is not going to
help much it probably will reduce it to
127 minutes so that that was not the
first thing we should have done so what
we looked into so we looked into the the
overall application as I was talking
about like you know application might
have several stages so this this
particular application are like close to
700 stages critical path time was like
3x the ideal application times what that
tells us that you know there is some
some level of reputation or looping or
or or some kind of skew happening then
we change the code to let's spark write
the partition in parallel so we figured
that you know there is a bottleneck at
the driver side but it was doing some
looping around it and doing some
operation which can easily be done you
know in parallel with executors and
there was the high partition loading so
then we change that code and then
further what we saw that the total wall
clock time went down to 26 minutes now
our critical path time was also 25
minutes but the ideal application time
still shows like you know the 4 minutes
so there was a lot of scope further we
looked into that and then this is the
projection I was talking about there is
a nice UI you can you can check the
report but this also tells you that you
know what what happens if you change
your executors how much it's gonna help
your you know the time a turnaround time
as well as the utilization so as you can
see from top to bottom
further down you might be you are
looking at the dropping utilization so
that's not the right thing to do
so I'm sorry I'm doing some fast-forward
here what further we did we basically
figured in the whole application that
there was a repartition logic written
somewhere by somebody and that was
narrowing down the whole application to
10 tasks while the application had so
many executors so that was one killer
thing which was actually why your ideal
application time was looking like four
minutes and it was not really producing
that result so what we change we change
the shuffle partition which is actually
which drives the number of pass for you
and we bumped it up to 200 and the
default 200 and the actual 800 and
finally this was the result so as you
can see the total wall clock time now
dropped to nine minutes and you know
critical paths and all those things were
pretty much in the neighborhood I think
that's the right right achievement or
right target we
you are pretty much in the neighborhood
that means your application is not
wasting too much time on like you know
stages where there are not enough tasks
or excuses skew problem is also not
there so that's the kind of results we
kind of got to and as you can see there
are just three passes I'm sure in
practicality I think my team actually
spent slightly more but I can tell you
if it was not for Sparkle ins and if I
had to do something by reading those
spark application UI metrics and all
those things you can imagine we were
talking about 697 stages it would have
been a nightmare and it would have taken
much longer so I think that's the result
we are not saying that spot line solves
every problem just like people sometime
interpret that they know a spark is
going to solve all of my problems
there's still some human factor but what
it gives you it gives you a very
scientific approach a very you know
result based metric based approach where
you can act on things without spending
time on experiments and measuring
results so I think this is it for today
I hope it made sense and I'm I'll be
very happy to take your questions now
couple of questions or I'll be in the
room and for the office hours thank you
very much
[Applause]